what goes through your mind when you
know you have a virus
that is killing people yeah you know you
have it and you can't go to the hospital
the hospitals told you not to go is it
terrifying to just sit at home and wait
to the point you're almost gonna die and
then knock down the door or the hospital
and ask them that's a fantastic question
and the short answer is my children my
children and my wife and my family was
obviously the first thing I'm thinking
about and yeah man I'm not gonna lie
like I said I stayed in our guest room
alone for like the first you know almost
two weeks where I was just by myself at
night I would distance myself from my
kids couldn't hug them or touch them
really yeah and the fear of am I gonna
wake up in the middle of the night not
able to breathe and are the hospital's
gonna be ready for you that is like a
literally like four day five day process
of thinking every night that is really
[ __ ] scary man yeah it was scary for
sure and then once I got to about day
eight or nine and I started to feel
better bro I was drinking like 11
bottles of water a day I was like they
were like you got a drink until your
piss is clear because when your piss is
clear like water clear that means you're
hydrated so like that was a big thing
vitamin D I took a lot of to build up
the immune system and stuff but uh I
think if I have to be honest the cigar
smoke can hurt me a little bit because
my wife really didn't have the the
coffee we only had a low-grade fever I
think one or two days but the COFF with
me especially in the throat and it you
know now I quit cigars man I mean I
don't think I'm ever going back really
yeah man cuz this yeah I mean listen if
I if in once the doctors are like good
but I'm worried I'm concerned I look at
my lungs find out what happened that's
it that's an interesting thing man how
how things could possibly change post
corona because so many probable VAP so
many people you know smoke hookah they
do all these things because the only
thing they're concerned about is
potentially lung cancer in the future
right they're like oh maybe I'll get a
little cancer when I'm [ __ ] 80 or
something like that you're never think
about that yeah but when you start
hearing it there's a vibe
could come around every single year and
if you got somewhat shitty lungs you
could be the one on the ventilator you
don't change in your life a little bit
man
and you said something important there I
think people that vape
I think vaping is a really [ __ ] bad
thing for this because there's a lot to
see what's that all the young people not
oh I don't want to put you know
misinformation but they say a lot of the
younger people that are out there that
are dying for this or they're on the
ventilators in the hospital have also
got vaping yes yeah and they were like
all they're healthy but it's like no
it's beating up their lungs I think
anybody with a compromised you no longer
respiratory system this is they're also
saying that even people twenty thirty
pounds overweight it's it's hurting them
too you know so um yeah man I'm just
listen if I was 55 or 65 it could be it
could definitely be different so and me
and my wife feel fortunate so now we
just got to check the blood and see if
we if we'll find out 100% if we did have
it which all indications that we did
right and then we're gonna find out if
we have antibodies antibodies for it but
I can tell you this losing your sense of
smell and taste for four [ __ ] nine
twelve days will [ __ ] is is wild [ __ ]